before we go you're gonna like this two  veterans teamed up to fight incredible  odds and a tremendous show of strength  John Nelson hiked 14 miles to the top of  mount Timpanogos in Utah over the  weekend you can see John's in good shape  but guess what  he did it with Jonathan Blanc strapped  to his back Nelson and Blanc served in  the same special operations unit of the  marine for 2010 Blanc lost his legs in  an explosion Afghanistan but he decided  not to let his injury stop him playing  skis he hunts he sails but he needed  some help to climb a mountain  that's when Nelson stepped up to the  challenge I got legs  I couldn't imagine if I shed a lot of  blood sweat and tears to get to where we  were and it was all worth it I'll say  the two men plan to hike up the tallest  mountain in California on Veterans Day  that's Mount Whitney Bravo